- Eigil0, I think you are
slowly turning me gay.
I might unsub, love the videos though.
(dance music)
Hey guys, excited to jump back into
the comments section.
Let's see what you gave me this week.
Fedora Miaza, dear Dr. Mike, what happens
if I get struck by lightning?
I think you get severely burned.
A lightning strike because
of electrical activity
can also stop your heart but I know people
who have gotten struck by lightning
at least from the news, and survived.
I've never seen a patient
get struck by lightning.
I think the odds are something like one
in 4,000 that you can
get struck by lightning.
We need to look that up.
I'll pop it up on screen in my edit,
Should a doctor treat relatives
or patients that they know?
If yes, how would it affect their
objectivity and judgement?
It depends on the doctor.
Some doctors can still be objective
in treating their friends and family.
Not ideal, because again you can make
some bad decisions when treating
your friends or family.
In fact, my dad whenever I was ill
even though he's a doctor he would always
take me to see another doctor
because he would say
like another set of eyes
that's not biased, that
doesn't see you every day.
They can sort of catch things that maybe
his eye won't catch and I agree with that.
Lois de Boer, career economics sentence
farmer judge stroke burning attributes
slam intense frankly.
Truth be told, George Washington's
pet puppy came at the
light of the bookshelf
on the TV stand who stood upon the
wires microphone et cetera.
Hope that answered your question.
(laughs)
What was that?
Karen Apellaniz, hey Dr.
Mike you are awesome.
Thank you.
I was wondering what body fat percentage
is too low for men or for women.
We hear a lot about being overweight
but commonly not about being too thin.
You look at Instagram and some of these
physiques that you see,
they're not realistic.
One of two things is happening.
You're either getting really extremely
plastic surgery or you're photoshopping
yourself to look thinner
than you actually are.
Now, the way that you should look at it
is not some much by
body fat but looking at
your BMI which compares your height
to your weight and
there's a chart for this
where you can actually see your height
and then match your weight and see
what number you are.
18.5 to 24.9 is the normal range.
Anything above 24.9 to 30 is overweight,
above 30 is obese, below
18.5 is underweight.
See where you fall in that little range
and then go talk to your doctor
and have a conversation about it.
Please make a podcast.
I would love to learn new things
from you during my commute.
Salls, I want to make a podcast.
I feel like I have a lot to say.
I've learned a lot on my journey
and while this is a great way for us
to communicate, I feel like a podcast
where I could sort of
just tell you how I feel
and talk about some current events,
maybe have some guests on the show
and have interesting conversations,
that's something I'm excited about.
Maybe Salls, you could do me a favor.
You could write a comment down below
and say anyone who wants Dr. Mike
to start a podcast, upvote this.
I'm going to give you a challenge.
20,000 upvotes, I will begin the process
of starting a podcast.
The challenge has been given.
Megan Meyer, hey Dr. Mike,
does Lightning McQueen
get car insurance or life insurance?
Lightning McQueen.
Lightning McQueen sounds like a character
from one of those things, Cars.
God, I'm so out of touch with reality.
That's what happens you're trapped
in a hospital all day.
If it's a car, I would say car insurance
because if a car dies the life insurance
company is going to sue
the car insurance company
and it's a whole lot of insurance nonsense
and I hate insurance.
This is why lawyers make so much money
and doctors don't because they bill
by like, the minute as opposed to doctors
we're all altruistic folks that
just want to help everybody.
Not hating on lawyers, you
do some great work also.
Do you have doctor related dreams?
For example, do you dream about medical
procedures, surgeries, et cetera?
Actually, Allison, I've
had some dreams like that
and they were nightmares.
Like, I would go in to inject a knee
with steroids for someone who has really
bad osteoarthritis and when I would start
injecting the steroid the knee just starts
swelling like crazy and
blood goes everywhere
and it was a legitimate nightmare
that I had over and over
again during my training.
I have no idea why.
HJK, hi Dr. Mike.
What is the science behind
being lactose and tolerant?
I think you mean lactose
intolerant, but I get it.
I am lactose intolerant and I have been
trying to drink milk more often
to help get my body liking it again.
Can that actually work?
Thank you.
Not a good idea because your body
is already saying that
it doesn't like milk.
When you're lactose intolerant,
you're not having an autoimmune reaction.
You're just missing the
enzyme that breaks down
the sugar component of
milk which is lactose
and the enzyme that
you're missing is lactase.
Sometimes people do well with a pill form
of the enzyme lactase.
It doesn't work for everybody
and it's sort of hit or miss.
My advice would be just
to skip out on dairy
foods as often as possible.
Make sure you're getting
calcium and Vitamin D
from other sources because usually that's
one of the main sources
of calcium and Vitamin D
for most folks, but if
you're going to enjoy
some cheese, some pizza, some cereal
make sure you do it when no one's around.
I know those symptoms can be rough.
(laughs)
How do I tell my doctor I have depression
because when I start to bring it up
I get anxiety and just back out?
Well, Angela, this is
sort of the doctor's job.
They're supposed to make
your feel comfortable.
They're supposed to ask you some
guided questions to allow you to express
the way you feel without
making you feel uncomfortable.
That doesn't mean there's
nothing to do on your part.
You should still really work to make sure
that your feelings come out honestly,
openly, and truthfully
because when you do that
not only will you get
a big sense of relief
by just getting that
information out there,
but then with that information the doctor
can then go ahead and help you.
It doesn't mean necessarily that they're
going to prescribe you a medication.
So many people are afraid
that, oh the doctor's
just going to tell me to take a pill
and I don't want to take a pill.
There are a lot of
treatments for depression
that are not just pharmacologic.
Don't feel down, Angela.
Stay confident, tell
your doctor the truth.
Be honest and open and reap the benefits
of getting your treatment.
Kelly Kawaguchi, does apple cider vinegar
really have all the
benefits that people claim?
No!
Apple cider vinegar is
not the next coming.
Honestly, I blame the media for this.
Someone came up with some study
that showed that in
mice there was a slight
decrease in blood sugar
levels in diabetic mice
and now they claim that apple
cider vinegar cures all.
It does not.
I do need to do a little bit more research
to find out exactly how
it effects each condition,
but I promise you it does
not solve every problem
and you shouldn't use it as
a cure all for everything.
In fact, I've seen some patients use it
and actually have some stomach upset
and have some other problems develop
as a result of using it.
Hey Dr. Mike, how often should you shower
for someone with eczema or dandruff?
Well, Cheeseguyguyguy1,
if you have dandruff
using a shampoo that is specifically
anti-dandruff shampoo is ideal.
You could also use some natural oils
like tea tree oil or
manuka oil or coconut oil.
I've seen some good results with that.
If you shower very often,
for someone who has
eczema you can overly dry out your skin
and cause eczema symptoms to get worse.
Also very important that
when you're susceptible
to eczema and you want to dry yourself
after the shower, don't rub your skin.
Just pat yourself dry so you don't
irritate the skin anymore
than it needs to be.
Hey Dr. Mike, I'm curious.
What is the most embarrassing
moment of your life?
Munise, I've said this
before and I'll say it again
and it's sad so get ready for a sad story.
I was four years old and my brain had just
turned on because I was making memories
and I remember this.
I was in pre-k and it was nap time
and I pooped my pants a little bit.
I had diarrhea and in Russia,
since they were very
strict and disciplinarian
if you will, they made
me walk around naked
while they washed my
underwear in the water
fountain in the sink and another teacher
walked in just as they were doing that
and I had to stand there naked.
Cold, it was cold too.
And they were cleaning out my poop.
It was very embarrassing.
That moment stuck with me.
I will never poop my pants again
until maybe I'm very, very old
and I'm incontinent and at which point
I will wear diapers so I don't have to
wash my underwear and I'll make sure
nobody has to see me nude except my nurse,
or my caretaker, or my
doctor, or my family members.
This has turned into a weird story
from a sad story and I'm
sorry you had to hear this.
(laughs)
I love responding and
reading your comments.
You guys crack me up with your questions.
I love trying these new formats also,
so if you have a format that you've seen
somewhere else or maybe you've created
in your mind and you want me to do it,
drop me a line down below in the comments
because I don't only
just respond to comments
in videos like this, I also jump
into the comments sections and respond
directly to folks.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat dance music)